economía en francés 24 con jorge hurtado
jorge las buenas noches para usted
igualmente ancla y comenzamos hablando
de la agencia calificadora fitch que
rebajó la calificación soberana de rusia
en seis escalones así de bueno la
calificación pasó de b a c y dijo que el
impago es inminente por las sanciones y
restricciones comerciales impuestos
occidente a rusia los mercados
financieros de rusia se han visto
sumidos en la confusión por las
sanciones occidentales tras la invasión
de ucrania y esto genera una enorme
preocupación sobre su capacidad de pago
de deuda la empresa de calificación
afirma que el aumento de estas sanciones
podrían limitar el comercio de energía
esto aumenta la probabilidad de una
respuesta política por parte de rusia
que incluye al menos el impago selectivo
de sus obligaciones a la deuda soberana
el 16 de marzo rusia debe pagar 107
millones de dólares en cupones de dos
bonos aunque tiene un periodo de gracia
de 30 días para poder realizar este pago
complicada la cosa cada vez más en torno
a rusia y bueno luego de conocerse el
veto al gas y el petróleo ruso por parte
de eeuu la otra gran noticia del día
virtual que también se había unido reino
unido- hay reacciones de los
consumidores así es la multinacional ese
shell british petroleum dijeron que
tendrían nuevas compras de petróleo y
gas como un importante endurecimiento de
estas sanciones contra moscú el crudo
brent de referencia internacional subió
más de un 5 por ciento al conocerse el
anuncio de job aid en los países de la
unión europea más dependientes del gas
ruso que eeuu se ha negado a tomar
medidas similares rusia representa
apenas el 8 por ciento de las
importaciones estadounidenses de
petróleo y productos derivados lo que
significa que el impacto en la mayor
economía del mundo sería algo llevadero
pero porque los otros países no se suman
a este evento la respuesta está en los
números de eeuu importaba unos 700 mil
barriles al día y los europeos unos 4,5
millones de barriles al día los
estadounidenses pagan ahora una media de
417 dólares por galón un aumento de 72
centavos en sólo un mes y el precio más
alto desde la recesión económica mundial
de 2008
bueno pues los números hablan por sí
mismos y no se nos olvide que es el tuvo
que salir a pedir disculpas por comprar
el crudo ruso después de que empezó a la
invasión a ucrania entretanto más
empresas se suman a las sanciones de
occidente y cancelan sus operaciones en
rusia asia y bueno las más recientes son
mcdonald's y starbucks y cocacola e
inclusive pepsi mcdonald que cerrará
temporalmente sus 850 locales en rusia
tras ser criticado por no haber actuado
con suficiente rapidez tras la invasión
de ucrania la empresa que cerró sus 100
locales ya en ucrania debido a la
invasión dijo que seguirá pagando a sus
62 mil empleados en rusia el primer
local de mcdonald's abrió en la céntrica
plaza pushkin de moscú en 1990 y se
convirtió rápidamente en un símbolo del
capitalismo estadounidense tras la caída
de la unión soviética
coca-cola por su parte y starbucks que
están deteniendo temporalmente las
operaciones comerciales en rusia
pepsi-cola anunció que suspendería a la
venta de refrescos en rusia pero no pero
que seguiría vendiendo productos básicos
como leche y fórmulas para bebé las
empresas están empezando a ceder a
medida que el número de muertes aumenta
en ucrania y millones de refugiados
huyen de este conflicto rusia que tiene
144 millones de habitantes es la
undécima economía del mundo y está
siendo aislada por fuertes sanciones de
occidente y finalmente con los precios
de las materias primas al alza ya se
habla incluso de una crisis alimentaria
así es ángela y es que los precios
mundiales de los alimentos alcanzaron su
nivel más alto en los 61 años de
historia del índice de precios de los
alimentos de la organización de las
naciones unidas para la agricultura y la
alimentación rusia y ucrania representan
buena parte de los suministros agrícolas
del mundo los países en conflicto
exportan trigo maíz aceite de girasol y
otros alimentos que suman más de una
décima parte de todas las calorías
comercializadas a nivel mundial por
ahora los envíos están ahí prácticamente
agotados según bloomberg el trigo ha
subido en 50 por ciento en dos semanas y
el maíz acaba de alcanzar su máximo de
toda una década este aumento puede
recaer sobre los bolsillos de los
ciudadanos de economías emergentes por
ejemplo que en latinoamérica donde los
alimentos representan una mayor parte de
la demanda los analistas predicen que
los flujos de exportación seguirán
interrumpidos en meses incluso angela si
la guerra terminará mañana pero otro de
los efectos se prevé en el sector
agrícola rusia es también un proveedor
importante de fertilizantes en estos
insumos los agricultores podrían
enfrentar retrasos en su producción
cosecha de café arroz y soya podrían
verse afectadas panorama globales
gracias a ustedes jorge y a nuestros
televidentes que se sigan con nosotros
hoy ya volvemos con más
y